This one's a compile time error. Let's see how this works in BlueJ. I'll make a
program and I'll put this line into it. Now I compile it and it says, cannot
find symbol, variable Hello. What do you think went wrong here? You can pause
the video and try and think about it for a second if you want. How would you
fix this error? The computer doesn't know what we mean by hello. And what we
wanted was hello Sarah to be literal text. In order to do that we need the
quatation marks. Let's see if it works now. Okay. Now there are no compile-time
errors. Let's try running it. Oops. It spelled my name wrong. There's no h in
my name. This would be considered a run-time error. This is a logic error, not
a syntax error.